rien de tel pour comprendre la technique
d'un sculpteur que de regarder ces
petites terres cuites qu'il malaxe pour
préparer cette culture parce qu'avant
d'être un bon marin très beau bronze
toulis une sculpture commence par un
petit tas de terre que le sculpteur va
travailler pour former son personnage
james pradier un des grands noms de son
temps grand sculpteur romantique comme
les autres à travailler la terre
on va tous retrouvés sur cette sculpture
ses empreintes digitales les traces de
ses ongles des petites boulettes de
terre qui juxtapose puis finalement de
trous dans son dos qu'est ce que ces
deux trous tout simplement l'emplacement
des ailes d'abord en papier qui finiront
en marbre plus tard dans son urne
alors james pradier comme tout le monde
beaucoup travaillé la terre mais n'a pas
conservé ses sculptures et le musée
d'orléans a eu la chance d'en posséder
deux malheureusement la guerre les a
toutes les deux des truites ont pris
l'ont finalement de serre artefacts de
la production fradier par chance un
généreux donateur vient de combler ce
manque de nous offrir cette belle terre
cuite qui montre que lui aussi il
mettait les mains à la pâte
[Musique]